yeah we gotta talk about this again hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by obey
fitness and we'll be taking a look at
fitness influencer whitney simmons but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
obey so pre pandemic going to different
workout classes was a major part of my
life but like most people i've really
gotten into the groove of working out at
home but i do find it hard to stay
motivated and keep my workouts really
interesting and fresh without having my
workout gang or an instructor leading me
through so i was really excited to try
out obey so obey is an at-home fitness
platform that features a huge variety of
boutique fitness classes they have 22
live classes a day 130 live classes per
week and over 8 000 on-demand classes
taught by some of the best instructors
in new york city and whether you're into
hit bar sculpt yoga ride dance you name
it there's over 20 different class
varieties to keep things interesting
they have classes in 5 10 15 45 and 60
minute lengths just depending on how
much time you have and they have options
for folks across fitness levels and
options depending on what equipment you
have they also have over 20 curated
structured programs ranging from seven
days to 30 days for folks who need a
little bit more of a routine or some
guidance and the class times start as
early as 6am and as late as 9pm so you
can fit it into your schedule i love the
bar and dance classes even my son likes
to try to join in because the time just
flies by they're just so fun and upbeat
and the ride classes are great for days
that i have a little more energy and i
really want to move there are really so
many different options with different
instructors and styles i'm confident i
am never going to get bored so if you
want to get started you can check out my
promo code abby month to get your first
month free and you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating so as always feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and if you are not already
subscribed hit that sub button and
follow me on tick tock and instagram
abby's kitchen so i reviewed whitney way
back in the day which you can check out
right here and i love that she actually
replied with gratitude for my
professional recommendations but a lot
of you guys have asked me to revisit
some of the og reviews so let's take a
look at how and what whitney is eating
today you know we could eat the exact
same meal the exact same portion we
could be doing the exact same workouts
lifting the same amount of weight and we
will still not look the same listen to
your hunger cues
visit a dietitian if you're needing more
guided help and i hope that you take
nothing from this video except some food
inspiration love the preface to this
video
this is also one of the reasons why i've
always been a fan of wit's content and
her influence in the fitness world
because she never really has been one to
pedal fad diets or pseudoscience or
restriction she's also scientifically
correct weight loss intervention studies
suggest that folks who eat the same
calories exact same will not have the
same weight loss outcomes thanks to
genetics metabolism microbiome diversity
energy needs and the thermic effect of
food remember folks what i eat in a days
should only be used for meal inspiration
not prescription so i am personally
ready to feel inspired
all right so i drizzled some mike's hot
honey on there we have the perfect egg
patty
[Music]
i am obsessed with mike's hot honey so i
am here for this combo right now we got
carbs from the english muffin tons of
protein from the turkey turkey bacon and
eggs and some healthy fats from the
avocado tasty balanced and i also love
the sweet salty spicy flavor profile i
also want to note that whitney has often
said that she is not gluten and
dairy-free because it's healthier but
because removing these from her diet has
helped her better manage her psoriasis
now we've briefly discussed psoriasis in
my downshiftology video right here but
in short we know that autoimmune
disorders like this often compromise gut
integrity making it more difficult to
tolerate a lot of different foods we
also often see that autoimmune disorders
tend to overlap so folks with psoriasis
are more likely to also have celiac
disease which would absolutely warrant a
gluten-free diet however there's no
standard diet protocol for psoriasis and
the evidence for eliminating gluten in
dairy is mixed and inconclusive probably
because it is highly individualized so
it's important to work with a dietitian
to tease out your unique food triggers
so that you can keep the widest variety
of foods possible in your diet while
still feeling good it's also just as
important to focus on foods that we can
add to help support the gut and reduce
the inflammatory response like omega-3
fats vitamin d selenium probiotics and
antioxidant rich foods taken i'm taking
a break from powdered pre-workout but if
i ever need like a little bit of energy
before my workout or in the middle of my
workout like a little mid-afternoon
pick-me-up but it's a mid-workout
picking me up i'll just sip on my
laundry new energy drink and i brought
my water out here
one drinks for fun
one drinks for hydration if you love
energy drinks to boost performance
during a workout fine i really don't
care how you get your caffeine but keep
in mind that drinks like the iolani new
energy drink contains around 200
milligrams of caffeine which is
equivalent to two cups of your usual
drip coffee or more than three shots of
espresso
so if you're sensitive to caffeine you
may want to be mindful of other sources
in the day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now that's how you do a post workout
we've got some fiber and healthy fats in
the avocado and since gluten-free breads
typically have less protein around 0.5
grams of protein per slice compared to
commercial breads which usually have
around three to four grams of protein i
do appreciate that we're making up the
difference with a little bit of protein
powder in the smoothie you mix up your
veggies depending on the day but you can
have everything prepared in the fridge
ready to go so i already had my black
beans rinsed washed ready to go
i am loving this deconstructed taco bowl
which can be easily made on the fly
using pantry staples so we're getting
lots of energizing carbs from the
tortilla rice and corn two sources of
protein from the black beans and the
ground meat and then we're getting some
veggies in there for some color
micronutrients and fiber with
my depression i had such a very very
very low appetite and so i've been
working very very slowly
to
increase my appetite again so back in
september 2021 whitney shared that she
was struggling with severe depression
and anxiety which was triggered by
losing a close friend to cancer while
also dealing with a lot of online
bullying so my heart goes out to whitney
and i absolutely applaud her for the
courage and vulnerability in sharing her
story we know how intimately connected
the brain and the gut are so it's very
common for depression to sometimes blend
hunger cues likely related to a
dysregulated nervous system and
increases in the stress hormone cortisol
now in some cases cortisol can cause
uncomfortable physical sensations like
nausea and tension which can cloud our
normal hunger cues depression can also
decrease our primal drive to maintain
daily activities of life like preparing
and eating healthy balanced meals now
with all that said when hunger cues are
blunted for whatever physiological or
psychological reason they can't really
be relied on exclusively for nourishment
which is why mechanical eating will
often be recommended in cases like this
so this would mean having set meal times
every day to ensure that you are getting
regular calories and nutrition in your
system as your body starts to
re-regulate even if your appetite
doesn't really agree with you at that
time and this is especially important
because a lack of calories and nutrition
can actually further exacerbate
depressive symptoms and negatively
impact energy levels which kind of
creates a bit of a vicious cycle it's
often important to have a handful of
super easy convenient meals on hand that
can be warmed up or whipped up really
quickly without thinking about it on
overwhelming days so whitney's protein
smoothie from earlier is a perfect
example of this as most folks with
really poor appetite will find that
drinking their calories are a lot easier
for them than eating them now i share
more tips on how to bump up the calories
and nutrition of food in my weight gain
video right here which can definitely be
applied in these cases as well lastly
well ultimately the goal for a lot of
folks with depression is just to eat
anything at all for days where we do
have a little bit more motivation
focusing on foods rich in omega-3 fats b
vitamins and protein may help to support
our mood-boosting neurotransmitters in
the brain
love this quick little hunger crushing
combo so we're getting some protein and
healthy fats from the peanut butter and
some fiber in the blueberries this would
be a really great easy snack idea for
days that you just like can't think
about meal prep
no let's finish off with dinner
[Music]
for a simple meal i gotta say like a
pecan crusted chicken it's quite
elevated in my books i mean it's a step
up from what i do on on really lazy
nights but nut crusting a lean protein
like chicken is a great way to boost
those calories and add some healthy fats
without too much fuss we've got protein
from the chicken fiber from the sweet
potatoes and green beans as well as some
healthy fats from the pecans so another
solid balanced meal that looks insanely
delish
delicious but on days when the energy
and motivation to cook is lower you
could easily swap in a little chopped up
rotisserie chicken throw a little salad
kit together on the side and then like
microwave some minute rice for some
carbs healthy balanced eating doesn't
have to be complicated so what are my
overall thoughts on whitney's diet based
on our calculations on this particular
day winnie's consuming a solid amount of
calories which i think are in line with
her needs a lot of people might be
thinking like oh wow that's a lot of
food but whitney is a very active young
woman with a solid amount of muscle mass
and that muscle mass is going to
upregulate our metabolism to support it
it's also not uncommon for folks who go
through depressive episodes and a low
appetite as a result of that to see
their body kind of play catch up when
they're feeling a little bit better so
that they can see larger than average
fluctuations in their daily caloric
needs but i do get the sense from
watching whitney often that she has a
generally healthy balanced relationship
with food with a focus on variety easy
meals and ultimately self-care and i
think that winnie is a perfect example
of how food and movement can be used as
a means for self-care rather than
self-control and how to treat yourself
and your body with kindness and
nourishment when times are tough so on
that note that's all that i have for you
guys today thank you again to obey for
sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who or what you'd like
senior review next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]